wir wollen zum mars aber erst mal
endlich zurück zum mond so ist der plan
der nasa doch die saturn 5 gibt es nicht
mehr und mit dem gewicht dass unsere
aktuellen raketen ins all befördern
können bekommen wir nicht mal einen
halben blauwal dort hoch so wird das
nichts mit dem aufbau einer mondbasis
geschweige denn unserem flug zum mars
deswegen fiebern alle gespannt auf den
jungfernflug des space launch systems
hin dass es
morgen soll es starten also hoffentlich
raketen starten ja erfahrungsgemäß noch
unpünktlicher als die deutsche bahn aber
egal ob es morgen losgeht oder erst in
ein bis zwei monaten hier erfahrt ihr
jetzt alles was ihr über die neue super
rakete der nasa wissen
[Musik]
es ist allerletzte eisenbahn nur noch
bis mittwoch den 31 august könnt ihr
dieses james webb t shirt hier bestellen
das wie designt haben danach geht es
endlich in die produktion und wird
danach vermutlich nie wieder produziert
also schlag zu wenn ihr auch eins haben
wollt bisher mir schon über 500
bestellungen von euch erhalten danke
dafür und ich habe noch eine weitere
ankündigung denn wir werden den ersten
start des sls live streamen und zwar auf
twitch bei arte zusammen mit move von
senkrechtstarter und zwar am montag um
14 uhr deutscher zeit seid dabei wenn
diese rakete zum ersten mal wieder
richtung mond startet und wir darüber
berichten und jetzt geht es los mit dem
video man könnte meinen es startet
einfach nur eine weitere rakete aber
tatsächlich ist dieser staat für die
gesamte menschheit relevant denn seit
ziemlich genau 50 jahren war kein mensch
mehr auf dem mond haben es nicht mal
jenseits der niederen erdumlaufbahn
geschafft warum das so ist dazu später
mehr jetzt ist erst mal wichtig wir
fliegen da nun endlich wieder hin und
vielleicht in wenigen jahren noch weiter
bis zum mars und zwar mit dem space
launch sytem dem sls hier kommen die
hard facts
[Musik]
die aktuelle version des sls namens
block 1 ist 98,1 meter hoch und die
stärkste aktuell fliegende rakete der
welt wenn sie denn morgen tatsächlich
startet damit löste die fällt im heavy
von spacex ab sie kann um die 95 tonnen
in die niedrige erdumlaufbahn befördern
bzw 27 tonnen zum mond für die von euch
die 70 tonnen für die erdumlaufbahn im
kopf haben das haben wir auch häufig
gefunden das war die ursprüngliche
anforderung vom kongress scheint aber im
laufe der zeit angepasst worden zu sein
die 95 tonnen sind zumindest die
aktuellste zahl die wir in einer nasa
quelle gefunden haben aber machen wir
weiter mit den fakten das sls wird orion
tausend mal weiter bringen als
gewöhnliche versorgungsflüge zur iss
orion wird von der rakete bis zu 39.000
429 kilometer pro stunde beschleunigt
das ist so schnell dafür habe ich
überhaupt kein irdisches vergleich 1100
unternehmen und verschiedenste nasa
center waren an der entwicklung der
neuen super rakete beteiligt und das
alles für ein ziel das sls ist teil der
artemis mission mit ihr will die nasa
endlich wieder zurück auf den mond und
auf lange sicht auch zum mars der plan
sieht wie folgt aus die artemis mission
ist in drei teile gesplittet im rahmen
von artemis 1 soll die rakete vor einen
mondflug entwickelt werden die inklusive
eines raumschiffs in den menschen ins
all befördert werden können das ist die
block 1 variante des sls und das orion
raumschiff parallel sollen die
entsprechenden start und lande systeme
entwickelt werden alles zusammen wird
beim jetzigen flug getestet
funktionieren sie sowie die ingenieure
sich das gedacht haben die entwickler
wollen bei der mission unter anderem das
hitzeschild von orion einem praxistest
unterziehen den einfluss von
mikrometeoriten dokumentieren und testen
wie lange daten brauchen um zwischen dem
raumschiff und der erde hin und her
geschickt zu werden wenn das alles
klappt dann geht es weiter mit der
zweiten projektphase und artemis 24 für
startete celeste block 1 zum ersten mal
mit menschen an bord wenn auch das
erfolgreich verläuft geht es an das
große ziel die mondlandung 2.0 oder auch
artemis 3 dafür soll es zusätzlich eine
dauerhafte station auf dem mond geben
wenn ihr noch mehr über artemis erfahren
wollt dann schaut euch doch unsere
videoreihe dazu an da haben wir ganz
ausführlich über atem ist 1 2 und 3
gesprochen die nasa hat also ganz schön
viel vor der erste start des sls ist nur
der erste schritt in einer langen reihe
von neuen meilensteinen und missionen
auch für die sls rakete selber wie eben
schon angedeutet ist dass sls bzw
eigentlich genauer gesagt sls block 1
nur der anfang es ist bereits seit
jahren geplant dass es nach diesem flug
noch zwei bis dreimal weiterentwickelt
wird wie seht ihr sls block 1 beeg
schuhe und die zwillingsschwester block
1b cargo das wie der name schon verrät
cargo transportieren kann klappt das
alles soll es ein weiteres upgrade in
sachen schwerlast geben mit einem
anderen triebwerk system und weiteren
ergänzungen soll die rakete als sls
block 2 eine last von bis zu 46 tonnen
zum mond befördern können oder 130
tonnen in die niedere erdumlaufbahn aber
man muss natürlich sagen auch wenn die
rakete neu ist haben die ingenieure und
ingenieurinnen selbstverständlich nicht
bei null angefangen viele einzelteile
sind weiterentwicklungen aus vorherigen
raketenprogramme so ist die apa stage
derzeit noch eine variante der apa stage
von der delta 4 und das orion raumschiff
ist ein überbleibsel aus dem ein
gestampften constellation programm
solche übernahmen verkürzten natürlich
die entwicklungszeit und sparen budget
trotzdem ist auch das sls mal wieder
viele jahre zu spät und viel teurer
geworden als geplant also ungefähr so
wie jeder zweite deutsche baustelle eine
baustelle die vielleicht der eine oder
andere bei sich selbst sieht an der aber
super einfach gearbeitet werden kann ist
englisch viele eigentlich fast alle der
quellen mit denen wir arbeiten sind auf
englisch umstellen und wieder vielleicht
eine sprachbarriere für euch da wer sein
englisch deshalb aufbessern möchte oder
noch mal grundlegend einsteigen will dem
kann ich kann sie empfehlen mit kambly
könnt ihr im individuellen
einzelgesprächen mit echten native
speaker neuer englisch verbessern ich
bin überzeugt dass man eine sprache am
besten lernt indem man sie ja eben
einfach spricht und ich habe kämen die
selbst auch schon ausprobiert die
tutoren sind alle super nett da braucht
euch echt gar keine sorgen über ihre
aussprache oder euren wortschatz zu
machen denn genau dabei wollen sie euch
helfen ihr habt bei camping die
möglichkeit euer alltagsenglisch noch
einmal aufzufrischen da könnt euch mit
speziellen lektionen auf die nächste
dienstreise oder den urlaub vorbereiten
oder auch speziell für eine lts prüfung
lernen die app ist also im grunde für
jeden etwas denn englisch ist in meinen
augen superwichtig und bringt euch auf
jeden fall weiter im leben mit unserem
coach doktor watson 30 könnt ihr jetzt
eine 15-minütige testsession
ausprobieren und spart sogar 30 prozent
wenn ihr dann einen drei monats abo
abschließt für die test session müsst
ihr übrigens keine bezahlt infos angeben
klickt einfach auf den ersten link unten
in der video beschreibung und dann viel
spaß beim lernen good luck in lübeck zu
dem video
das sls ist eine krasse neue rakete
keine frage aber es gab doch bereits
starke raketen oder nicht was ist denn
mit dem starship von spacex oder mit der
saturn 5 selbst in ihrer stärksten
fortentwicklung wird das sls nicht die
stärkste rakete die je gebaut wurde die
saturn 5 die bis vor knapp 50 jahren
flog konnte bis zu 130 tonnen in die
niedere erdumlaufbahn und 49 5 tonnen
zum mond transportieren also etwas mehr
als der finale sls block 2 beim
vergleich mit der rakete starship die
space ex baut muss man etwas
differenzieren das sls kann in seiner
aktuellen ausführung weniger als das
wieder verwendbare starship in den
himmel transportieren im finalen design
als block 2 aber wahrscheinlich mehr so
genau weiß man das nicht denn bei ihrem
us raum fahrzeugen kann sich ja
bekanntlich bis zum start erst mal noch
alles verändern ursprünglich sollte es
da schon mal 300 tonnen transportieren
können soviel dazu aber so oder so ist
das hat ja noch nicht geflogen dafür
wird ein flug mit dem starship
höchstwahrscheinlich deutlich günstiger
sein als ein staat mit dem sls butter
anderem weil die teile des star schrieb
wieder verwendbar sein soll die sls
antriebe aber nicht das ist lässt
wiederum muss für einen flug inklusive
landung auf einem der gestirne nicht in
der erdumlaufbahn nachgetankt werden
beim starship ist das notwendig mehr
dazu was basics mit dem star zuvor hart
und wie es funktioniert erfahrt ihr
übrigens in diesem video hier aber lasst
uns doch mal die jetzige mission genauer
anschauen denn sie ist wirklich mega
spannend
das sls wird von zwei boostern und 4er
s25 triebwerken in die luft katapultiert
anschließend separieren sich die booster
und die rakete macht sich auf dem weg
raus aus der erdumlaufbahn
ungefähr zwei stunden nach dem start
gibt es eine weitere trennung danach ist
das raumfahrzeug orion alleine auf dem
weg zum mond hier kommt jetzt ein
service modul von der esa ins spiel von
der europäischen raumfahrtagentur es ist
die versorgungseinheit und stellt unter
anderem elektrizität luft und wasser für
eine potentielle crew bereit seine
funktionalität soll bei diesem flug noch
mal ganz besonders getestet werden bevor
es dann zum ersten mal menschen
beherbergen soll die aktuelle flugroute
sieht vor dass es von der erde aus durch
den von allen gürtel vorbei am
gps-satelliten netzwerk und ab zum mond
geht nach wenigen tagen fliegt das
raumschiff in nur 100 kilometern
entfernung an ihm vorbei und zwei bis
dreimal drumherum anschließend geht es
zurück wieder am mond vorbei und
richtung erde nach drei bis sechs wochen
und um die rund zwei millionen
zurückgelegten kilometern tritt die
orion kapsel dann wieder in die
erdatmosphäre ein bei voraussichtlich
2007 160 grad celsius
zum ersten mal seit 50 jahren machen wir
uns also wieder auf den weg zurück zum
mond aber wie kam es dazu dass wir
aktuell nicht dorthin fliegen können
obwohl wir das eigentlich mal konnten
wie konnte uns dieser technische
meilensteine verloren gehen die antwort
müssen wir vielleicht gar nicht bei der
technik suchen dann raumfahrt- und die
entwicklung von raketen ist extrem teuer
und wurde in der vergangenheit fast
ausschließlich von staaten finanziert
und wofür starten ihr geld ausgeben ist
eine frage der politischen agenda und
der gesellschaftlichen prioritäten
vielleicht das ist jetzt meine vermutung
war ein flug zu einem himmel stören in
den letzten jahrzehnten einfach nicht
wichtig genug für unsere gesellschaft um
so viel geld da rein zu investieren
jetzt sollen aber endlich wieder
menschen zum mond starten irgendwann
sogar zum mars wenn alles glatt geht
müssen wir nicht mal viele jahre lang
auf den nächsten start warten denn die
orion-kapsel für die atem ist zwei
missionen es tatsächlich schon fertig
und bereits letzten dezember von bremen
da bremen zum kennedy space center
transportiert worden auch andere
raketenteile sind bereits fertig und
werden parallel zum a-team ist ein start
langsam für ihren eigenen staat
vorbereitet 2024 ist derzeit als ziel
für die erste artist 2 rakete geplant
solange müssen aber zum glück nicht auf
das nächste doktor watson video warten
wir sehen uns schon nächste woche wieder
bis dahin bleibt neugierig und fliegt
nicht zu weit raus
es geht um das
wild
schluss